Dominique Lapointe bonsoir bonsoir
est-ce que les hausses de taux d'intérêt
est-ce qu'il est clair pour vous que les
hausses de taux d'intérêt au Canada sont
toutes derrière nous non la bande du
Canada on pense aimerait mais tenir le
taux directeur à 4,5 % jusqu'à la fin de
l'année mais cependant elle est
surprises on est aussi surpris par la
vigueur de l'économie canadienne en
début d'année la vigueur de la
croissance mondiale donc ce matin dans
le communiqué on ne parle plus de
laisser les toits échangés même comme on
le faisait en janvier on parle on est en
train de révaluer si on les a assez
montés donc ça donne le signal que si
d'ici la prochaine décision ou peut-être
celle d'après au mois de juillet
l'économie continue de surperformer on
pense qu'on atteindra pas la cible qu'on
avait mentionné de 2% en 2024 qu'on va
devoir rehausser les taux une ou deux
fois de plus bientôt mais en même temps
la banque maintient ses cibles en disant
on s'en va à 3 % cet été on s'en va à 2
% l'an prochain
la banque semble assez à l'aise avec ce
parcours cours de d'abaissement
d'inflation effectivement les données
d'inflation sont assez en ligne avec ce
qu'on s'attendait même que certaines
mesures diminuent plus vite que prévu
mais par contre pour ce qui est du
ralentissement économique on s'attend
quand même à ce que ça ralentit ça c'est
pour que la demande dans l'économie soit
en bas de l'offre ce qui pourrait
ramener l'inflation à la hausse plus
tard cette année donc c'est pour soi
qu'on ramène aussi cet avertissement là
et aussi le canal de la communication on
veut vraiment ancrer les attentes en
disant ne vous attendez pas des baisses
de taux on va les laisser stable ou même
les monter pendant plus longtemps donc
ça ça va te ça diminue les attentes pour
les consommateurs parce que les attentes
sont importantes en économie et les
attentes d'inflation les attentes de
baisse de taux si on évoque beaucoup de
baisse de taux le comportement du
consommateur sera différent
effectivement pour donner un exemple on
a eu une baisse assez importante des
taux obligataires dans les derniers mois
en raison du stress dans les banques
mondiales ce qui a AMEN une baisse du
taux hypothécaire légère au Canada fixe
qui provient du fait que le taux
obligataire à 5 heures par exemple au
Canada a baissé donc si les gens se
disent en ce moment les taux
hypothécaires baisse beaucoup c'est le
moment d'entrer dans le marché je pense
pas que la Banque du Canada désire une
remontée du marché immobilier avec les
prix à ce moment-ci la Banque du Canada
et c'est pas la première fois que TIF
maclem en parle
se dit que les salaires devraient
augmenter de façon plus modérée c'est
pas agréable d'entendre ça parce que
tout le monde veut des hausses de
salaire importantes mais c'est
inflationniste et hausses importantes de
salaire ouais parce que les compagnies
se sentent obligés c'est un coût fixe ce
sont obligés de refiler ce coup-là au
consommateur qui eux ensuite de ce sont
aussi des travailleurs qui vont
redemander un salaire plus éliminé pour
compenser donc c'est pour ça qu'on
s'attend à une modération à ce moment-là
c'est ce qu'on veut éviter mais ceci
étant dit on ne l'a pas vu cette spirale
en ce moment-là la croissance des
salaires elle est stable elle est encore
trop élevé pour la vente Canada est
encore bien en haut de la cible on est
autour de 5%, mais on n'a pas vu cette
spirale là donc c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut dire qu'on a bien invité pour
l'instant mais est-ce que la banque
s'inquiète qu'il y a une spirale
inflationniste lié justement au salaire
peut-être plus l'an dernier en mesure
quelle inflation était plus autour de 8%
les attentes inflationnistes étaient
plus élevées là on voit que les attentes
inflationnistes sont quand même baissés
même celles des entreprises dans le
sondage auprès des entreprises de la
vente du Canada nous disent que les
pénurie de main d'oeuvre sont moins
élevées et puis on s'attendent
stabilisation des stars est-ce que
l'enjeu de la dette des ménages parce
que beaucoup de ménages de plus en plus
endettés puis avec la hausse des taux
d'intérêt ça change le portrait de
l'endettement inquiète la Banque du
Canada c'est pas évident il le voit
comme une vulnérabilité ça a toujours
été comme ça qu'on le formule c'est une
vulnérabilité mais on a vu que cette
vulnérabilité là c'est accrue pendant la
pandémie puis s'accroît à mesure que les
taux hypothécaires augmentent puis les
gens doivent refinancer à des dos plus
élevés donc pour nous il va y avoir un
choc de refinancement puis à ce
moment-là la consommation va prendre
diminuer plus vite que ce que la Banque
du Canada s'attendent un choc de
refinancement au moment de refinancer
son hypothèque et celui-là que l'effet
des taux d'intérêt 18 mois 12 18 24 mois
plus tard va vraiment se faire sentir
l'aspect hypothécaire qui est au Canada
est plus important mais il y a aussi le
coût de financement des entreprises ça
coûte beaucoup plus cher que financer
sur les marchés ça coûte beaucoup plus
cher avoir un prêt auprès des banques
aux États-Unis même on remarque les
conditions de près n'ont jamais été
aussi assez serré à moins d'envenir à
une récession donc ce n'est pas de bonne
longueur donc l'effet des taux d'intérêt
plus élevés ça laisse de multiples
canaux la Banque du Canada a dit
aujourd'hui l'économie américaine va
ralentir significativement faisant écho
à l'incertitude bancaire notamment ce
serait quoi l'impact pour l'économie
canadienne c'est qu'on exporte beaucoup
encore 80% nous exportations va vers les
États-Unis beaucoup de biens et on
s'attend à ce que la consommation de
bien qui est excessive qui a été
accessible depuis la pandémie aux
Etats-Unis au Canada aussi d'ailleurs
diminue plus fortement que les services
donc disproportionnellement nos
exportations vont être touchées ce qui
fait que l'impact direct qui va nous
frapper au troisième trimestre mais dans
les chiffres de croissance économique
présenté aujourd'hui par la Banque du
Canada pour le Canada on a l'impression
qu'on voit pas de récession ou ça
s'appelle pas une récession
c'est on n'est pas on n'est pas
récession puis on s'en va pas récession
au Canada finalement c'est ce qu'on nous
dit c'est la prévision de la banque
Canada c'est à dire des taux de
croissance aux alentours de 1% pour le
reste de l'année
est-ce que ça implique qu'on n'aura pas
d'un choc de refinancement de vie quand
j'ai mentionné est-ce que ça implique
que la construction par exemple qui a
pas baissé beaucoup ne va pas diminuer
est-ce que la consommation va pas
diminuer plus que ce qu'on espère nous
notre prévision par exemple elle est un
peu plus pessimiste sur ce qu'on prévoit
quand même une contraction de l'économie
canadienne à partir du troisième
trimestre qui va durer peut-être trois
trimestres donc il va mettre la bande du
Canada dans une position vers la fin de
l'année
cumuler à l'inflation qui a baissé qu'on
va devoir baisser les taux
très intéressant Dominique Lapointe
merci pour cette analyse merci beaucoup
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]